As Julius Robert Oppenheimer witnessed
the successful detonation of the world’s
first nuclear weapon, he was
haunted by its implications.
I remembered the line from the Hindu
scripture, the Bhagavad Gita…Now
I am become Death, the destroyer of worlds. I
suppose we all thought that. One way or another.
Oppenheimer was a man of many talents.
He spoke eight languages.
Wrote poetry.
Yet he will forever be remembered
as the father of the atomic bomb.
The man who gave people the power to destroy
themselves was haunted by his own creation.
When people first met J. Robert Oppenheimer, what
was immediately obvious to them was his intellect.
A former colleague once said: "The man
was unbelievable! He always gave you the
right answer before you formulated the question."
Knowledge came easy to Oppenheimer.
He learned Dutch in six weeks just
so he could give a lecture while
on a visit to the Netherlands.
He was born in New York on April 22, 1904,
the older son of German Jewish immigrants.
His father, Julius, was a textile
importer who became very wealthy.
His mother was a painter whose family
had been in New York for generations.
He was raised in Manhattan on the upper west side
in an apartment adorned with paintings
by famous artists, including Van Gogh.
After attending an elite private school in
New York City, he went on to Harvard in 1922,
intending to become a chemist
but leaving with an appetite
for physics. Ethical Culture Society School
He had been attracted to experimental
physics after taking a course
on thermodynamics at Harvard.
He also studied philosophy, Greek, and
French literature. Ethical Culture School
He spent his days living in the library,
raiding the place intellectually, as he put it.
He enrolled at Harvard a year late
due to suffering from colitis,
an inflammatory bowel disease, but he made up for
it by graduating in three years instead of four.
He then crossed the pond to
the University of Cambridge
to conduct research at the Cavendish
Laboratory for experimental physics.
However, he was clumsy in the lab and realized his
forte was not in experimental work
but rather in theoretical physics.
The stress of grad work threw him into
depression and he became emotionally unstable.
He even confessed to lacing an apple with harmful
chemicals in an attempt to poison his tutor with
whom he didn’t get along. Fortunately, the
tutor didn’t eat the apple. (Patrick Blackett)
Oppenheimer left Cambridge to continue his
studies at one of the centers of theoretical
physics in Europe, the University of
Göttingen (Goat-ting-in) in Germany.
He produced good work and held his
own despite his youth. He was only
23 years old when he received his Ph.D.
He subsequently returned to the U.S. where he
worked as a research fellow at Harvard and then
the California Institute of Technology, Caltech.
He was so absorbed in his studies
that he often ignored the real world.
But the rise of fascism in Europe
in the 1930s caught his attention.
Oppenheimer agreed with Einstein
that German scientists could
make a nuclear weapon and when they
did, Hitler was prepared to use it.
America watched fearfully as the
Nazis invaded Poland in 1939.
In 1942, Oppenheimer was selected
to direct the Manhattan Project,
a top-secret U.S. Army project
to develop the atomic bomb.
He brought together the best minds in physics
and eventually managed more than 3,000 people.
He chose Los Alamos, New Mexico as the
primary production facility because of
its natural beauty. He had fallen in
love with the mountains and plateaus
when he traveled there as a teen during his
gap year as he recovered from ill health.
Washington threw ridiculous amounts
of money at the project. An initial
budget of $6,000 eventually ballooned
into a whopping $2 billion by 1945!
Before heading the Manhattan Project,
Oppenheimer taught physics at both Caltech
and the University of California, Berkeley,
where he built the physics program and turned
it into the hub for physics research in America.
He had already been working on
nuclear fission - the powerful
release of energy caused by
the splitting of an atom.
The best element for splitting is the
heaviest element found in nature, uranium.
A uranium atom has 92 protons and 146 neutrons,
giving an atomic mass of 238, or U238.
A small portion of uranium that’s mined has
the same 92 protons; however, it only has 143
neutrons, giving us U235. This is highly unstable,
which makes it highly splitable or fissionable.
When it’s slammed by a neutron, it becomes U236.
It’s so unstable that it splits into two atoms,
krypton and barium.
In the process,
three more neutrons are released. They
fly out and slam into more U-235 atoms,
causing a chain reaction and
ultimately a huge explosion.
Kind of like when you throw a bowling ball
and the pins jump and strike other pins,
and those pins smash into other pins
- all of the energy is released.
Research also showed that plutonium 239
would be highly fissionable. However,
it’s not a naturally occurring
element and had to be manufactured.
Reactors were built in southeastern
Washington state to produce the plutonium.
And then….
On July 16, 1945, scientists detonated a plutonium
bomb over the small town
of Alamagordo, New Mexico.
We knew the world would not be the same. A
few people laughed. A few people
cried. Most people were silent.
Never before had humanity possessed a weapon
that posed a threat to global civilization.
The test's success meant an atomic bomb
was ready to be used by the U.S. military.
The following month, the U.S. military
dropped two atomic bombs on Japan.
On August 6, 1945, the most powerful
weapon in the world was dropped on the
Japanese city of Hiroshima. 140-thousand
people were killed, many vaporized.
Thousands more would die in pain in the months
and years that followed from radiation poisoning.
Three days later, another bomb fell on Nagasaki,
killing 74,000 people with
equally devastating effects.
Japanese Emperor Hirohito decried the
devastating power of “a new and most cruel bomb.”
Japan surrendered six days later,
abruptly ending World War Two.
Oppenheimer initially expressed
guilt over his creation.
He said the weapon had "dramatized so mercilessly
the inhumanity and evil of modern war."
He continued: "In some sort of crude sense which
no vulgarity, no humor, no overstatements can
quite extinguish, the physicists have known sin;
and this is a knowledge which they cannot lose."
Yet a decade later, he appeared to distance
himself from personal responsibility, pinning
it on the state, saying: "I carry no weight on my
conscience. Our work has changed the conditions in
which men live, but the use made of these changes
is the problem of governments, not of scientists."
After the war, he became a key
advisor on U.S. atomic policy.
He headed the principal advisory committee
of the successor to the Manhattan Project,
the Atomic Energy Commission.
The Commission was a civilian
agency in control of nuclear
research and the development of nuclear weapons.
He even had a desk in the President's Executive
Offices across the street from the White House.
But then…things began to turn against Oppenheimer.
In December 1953, President
Dwight Eisenhower ordered
that a "blank wall be placed between
Dr. Oppenheimer and any secret data.”
Oppenheimer was suspected
of being a communist spy.
He argued he was never interested
in politics and economics.
He apparently wasn’t even aware of the stock
market crash of 1929 until after the fact.
However, he started connecting with
left-leaning groups in the thirties
and forties after falling for Jean Tatlock.
In 1936, friends introduced
Oppenheimer to the grad
student who was studying psychology at Stanford.
Tatlock was extremely involved
with politics. She was a member
of the Communist Party of America and
supported many left-leaning causes.
Oppenheimer inherited hundreds of thousands
of dollars after his father’s death in the
thirties and began supporting left-wing efforts
such as the Loyalists in the Spanish Civil War.
They had a passionate relationship
and were together for several years,
coming close to marriage, but ultimately broke up.
He went on to marry Kitty Puening
in 1940. She was a Berkeley student
and was at one time a Communist Party
member. They had two children together.
He still continued to see his former love and
spent a night with Tatlock while working on the
secret bomb project in 1943. Tatlock told him
she still loved him. He never saw her again.
She was a complicated person and is said
to have struggled with her sexuality. She
also suffered from intense depression
and would take her own life in 1944.
Perhaps it was Tatlock’s love of the English poet
John Donne that compelled Oppenheimer to name the
first test of the atomic bomb “Trinity”, inspired
by Donne’s sonnet about a three-personed God.
Although Oppenheimer’s communist affiliations
were clearly known - they didn’t stop him from
getting hired on to lead the Manhattan Project.
The FBI saw no reason to revoke his security
clearance when they conducted
an investigation in 1944.
However, the onset of the Cold
War brought renewed scrutiny.
The Soviet Union conducted its first
successful nuclear test in 1949,
ahead of America’s estimates.
People within the government
were suspicious of Oppenheimer.
William Liscum Borden, executive director of
the United States Congress Joint Committee on
Atomic Energy, had sent a letter
to FBI director J. Edgar Hoover
concluding “more probably than not J. Robert
Oppenheimer is an agent of the Soviet Union.”
He didn’t back up his claim
with any solid evidence.
Borden was close to the chairman of
the Atomic Energy Commission Lewis
Strauss who hated Oppenheimer. The two
butted heads and Strauss never forgot
when Oppenheimer humiliated him at a
Congressional hearing years earlier.
In 1954, Oppenheimer was called before a tribunal
of the Atomic Energy Commission to
explain his communist affiliations.
It was a closed-door hearing
that lasted four weeks.
Oppenheimer maintained that he had not been
radicalized by his ex-partner, and said his
left-wing friends and associations simply gave
him a sense of companionship – nothing more.
He had never been a Communist
party member himself.
Three board members heard his case.
By a vote of two to one, they stripped
him of his security clearance.
The guy who delivered the verdict was
none other than Strauss, who hated him.
Oppenheimer was humiliated.
The once powerful scientist lost all his power.
The U.S. government no longer trusted the
U.S. government’s top atomic physicist.
His scientific peers were outraged.
Einstein quipped that the “AEC” in
Atomic Energy Commission actually
stood for “Atomic Extermination Conspiracy”
Wernher von Braun, the chief architect
of the Saturn V that got us to the moon,
declared: “In England, Oppenheimer
would have been knighted.” By the way,
I did a story on von Braun’s past as a Nazi
scientist which I’ll link in the description.
But at least one scientist
was pleased with the outcome.
Hungarian physicist Edward Teller resented
the fact that Oppenheimer resisted working
on the hydrogen bomb - which is the more
advanced version of an atomic bomb.
When President Truman approached the Commission
in 1949 about building a hydrogen bomb,
Oppenheimer opposed it, to the anger of Teller.
The US pressed ahead with developing a
thermonuclear weapon anyway and tested
it in 1952 on the Marshall Islands.
The H-bomb became Teller’s baby.
During the Oppenheimer hearing, Teller testified:
“I would feel personally more secure if
public matters would rest in other hands.”
For his testimony, Teller was shunned by
the scientific community for many years.
Today, hundreds of declassified pages from the
secret hearings have revealed
Oppenheimer was not disloyal.
The U.S. Department of Energy concludes
“...it proved impossible to link his lack
of enthusiasm for the hydrogen bomb
with suspicions of his disloyalty.”
Producing another weapon with the
potential to be a thousand times
more powerful than the atomic bomb
was unfathomable to Oppenheimer.
He felt the hydrogen bomb was unnecessary and
immoral, fearing its use against civilians.
He had used his position on the Atomic Energy
Commission to lobby for international control
of nuclear weapons to avoid a nuclear
arms race with the Soviet Union.
With his security clearance revoked, he
settled in Princeton, New Jersey where
he still ran the Institute for Advanced Study,
a research facility for postdoctoral fellows.
He lived quietly until President John
F. Kennedy invited him to the White
House dinner of Nobel Prize winners in 1962.
Oppenheimer never won a Nobel prize himself,
though he was nominated for the
prize in Physics three times.
When the Kennedy administration offered him
a new trial to potentially get his
security clearance back, he declined.
Further evidence that the government
was warming up to him came in 1963 when
President Johnson awarded him
one of the highest scientific
honors bestowed by a president, the Fermi
Award, which comes with $50,000 tax-free.
In response, Oppenheimer said: "I think
it is just possible, Mr. President,
that it has taken some charity and some
courage for you to make this award today."
Two years later, in 1965, Oppenheimer
was diagnosed with throat cancer. He
had been a notorious chain smoker all his life.
The New York Times once described
him “as thin as the wisps from his
chain-smoked cigarettes or pipes”.
On February 18, 1967, he died at his
home in Princeton. He was 62 years old.
His wife took his ashes to the island of
Saint John in the U.S. Virgin Islands,
where he lived for several months
of the year, and spread his ashes
in the sea outside of their home, in an
area known today as “Oppenheimer Beach.”
The twentieth century marked a new age in which
the very existence of humankind was threatened.
That threat is more real than ever today with
fears that Russia could use
nuclear weapons in Ukraine.
North Korea’s missile launches in October were a
simulation to “wipe out” South Korean
targets, according to state media.
The Doomsday Clock warns we are
getting closer to destroying our world.
At the beginning of the Cold War,
we were 7 minutes to midnight.
Today, we’re 100 seconds to midnight.
If you’ve been inspired by Oppenheimer’s
story and wish to improve your STEM skills,
Brilliant is the best way to learn math,
science, and computer science interactively.
I’ve been going through their Logic courses myself
to help improve my critical thinking skills. I
love that it’s super interactive.
There’s something for everyone.
You can learn to program drones
in an Amazon warehouse to help you
think algorithmically in their computer science
fundamentals course, and no coding is required.
You can make sense of the world by exploring
the laws of physics and the principles of
engineering through their Scientific Thinking
course. But instead of complex mathematics and
number crunching, you can learn through
physical insight by solving puzzles.
For math enthusiasts, there are so many
mathematics courses to choose from. You
can start your Algebra journey with
Brilliant’s pre-Algebra course that
will sharpen your problem-solving skills and
explore what’s really useful about Algebra.
Brilliant is for people of all experience
levels. Whether you’re a student or you’re
already working and want to brush
up on what you already know.
Brilliant is free for you to try out if
you use the custom link in my description:
brilliant.org/newsthink.
And the first 200 people who
sign up with my link will get 20% off their
annual Premium subscription, which gives
you access to all of their offerings,
including their most advanced courses.
Thanks for watching. For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.